[Music]
ha oh yeah
is the Sunday night podcast one of the
best bands God ever put on this [ __ ]
planet understanding dirty white
[ __ ] at their best
Einstein can suck my dick these
[ __ ] of geniuses
[Music]
[Music]
I'm finally back bad banana that down
just when you thought it was safe
[ __ ] Yahoo Joey invade the
[ __ ] airway Oh
[Music]
Danka not stop today
are you [ __ ] kidding me [ __ ]
Allman Brothers solutionist
[ __ ] that I know
Oh
[Music]
and you said can you help Oregon
[Music]
here we go [ __ ] what oh [ __ ]
there's a white people or white people
is before peanut allergies and [ __ ]
people can about Trump and Hillary
nobody gave a [ __ ]
listen to the shade they gave a flock
about pumping the Koreans didn't give a
[ __ ] about the Koreans with Korea's get
sucked in
did you follow me
Oh
[Music]
oh [ __ ] you bad [ __ ] uncle Joey
here ripping and rocking bong hits wall
you [ __ ] Jesus had to die for
our sins I'm dying for your [ __ ]
sends you dirty [ __ ] we're here
on a Sunday night with the bond of life
our bag of stars and two [ __ ] guns you
follow me everything else is up to you
we're going over the 10 greatest albums
of all time for that are you [ __ ]
kidding me
a little either peach not a good [ __ ] we
got in there here we go are you [ __ ]
kidding me Jesus it's what I'm talking
about you don't get this no more Oh baby
I just don't know are you [ __ ] nuts
you might as well break Athea
grandmother's [ __ ] medicine cabinet
as this is it this is gonna take you
into deep waters tonight it's a great
[ __ ] week the first week of the year
is done you follow me the first week
suck your dick like one of Harvey what
ever Lee Harvey Weinstein's youngest
actresses they can suck your dick you
follow me we're going into the second
week and we don't give a [ __ ] the rest
of the week the rest of the country is
freezing we're gonna get a little rain
come on people white people already
scattering and [ __ ] they got a winter
weather report coming on at 4:00 in the
morning that let you know what routes to
take who gives a [ __ ] I know no way yeah
I ain't going nowhere kind of suck cuz
I'm Joey staying at the [ __ ] Casa
Farley I got jujitsu and lunch and I got
Mercy's birthday tomorrow five [ __ ]
years oh can you believe that five five
five I kept her alive two [ __ ] five
I'm gonna go get a car though take them
off and get this [ __ ] party started
but keep talking about parties look what
we got a full [ __ ] batch of uh Cinco
Cinco Cinco Cinco these are them right
here [ __ ] we're going deep
tonight Oh
[Music]
just like that
it's like vitamin C it's like eatin
[ __ ] French flicks don't [ __ ] fight
if you follow me I can do these all day
long all day long throw them down the
[ __ ] pipe all day long [ __ ] up you
don't huh really crying about it yeah
that's why that's why you don't love
these things tonight these are [ __ ]
hummus flavored sure look at this this
is the left this is the three wise men
showed up with this is what they brought
Jesus a star of [ __ ] death you follow
me leave [ __ ] I thought we're
breaking the home record leak so get
ready to go yeah eat that one from the
floor a friend ate one from the [ __ ]
floor and he [ __ ] ended up in the
hospital he blamed it on subway was
subway he went the subway sandwich had a
6-inch veggie and cheese ended up in the
[ __ ] Hospital and that's what the
cheese can you imagine eating there
[ __ ] turkey meat there's what I've
been talking about for years people I'm
gonna stop with the imagine that born on
a diet on lettuce in your leg
but yeah a [ __ ] lettuce like a rabbit
eat with G stay away from that [ __ ]
iceberg lettuce and switch over the
spinach leaf so whatever the [ __ ] Popeye
Popeye eat sea stars of debt that's a
Popeye each [ __ ]
[Music]
that's goalie we're going deep tonight
those are the bronchitis killers what's
going on with the bronchitis all right
we're gonna do fungus on Wednesday we
gotta take it back into the murky waters
this bronchitis excuse it's [ __ ] done
you're fine I'm drunk either who gives a
[ __ ] I know a guy that's missing two
lungs he still doing bong hits every
[ __ ] morning it's what's in your
[ __ ] heart you follow me [ __ ]
and don't forget January 18th Austin
Friday and Saturday is already [ __ ]
sold out the rest is up to you little
dirty bestest then the week after that
we're taking that [ __ ] party Caravan
the Charlotte North Carolina I'll be
there 25th 26th and 27th I'm letting you
know right now so there's no
misunderstandings I don't want you
hitting me out the day up on Facebook
Joey I got no tickets I don't even take
Facebook with me I don't get the message
I get back on Sunday say you're [ __ ]
anyway anyway it's a whole new week with
a whole new set of rules if you want
2018 and suck your dick it starts now
right you [ __ ] around all week I'm
waiting for the ball game to go on my
diet
who gives a [ __ ] about the boat game do
what you do now [ __ ] tomorrow
never comes
hold on bong it's for Jeff Sessions
while we're on it that's a new segment
on the church what's happening now bong
hits for Jeff Sessions [ __ ] that Lee
does he's a dick sup that's why he's out
of his mind he gives a [ __ ] you can't
arrest nobody got nothing Jeff session
got nothing you know I'm saying he got
who got [ __ ] Jeff Sessions to the
[ __ ] truth and the donkey who brought
him in is this the church or what's
happening now we do what the [ __ ] we
want when it comes to reefing you follow
me you want to put me behind bars for
reefer go-go fault go for it
[ __ ]
I got a Jew attorney he'll break this
whole Constitution down in shape
now you got Columbus Day overturn now
get the [ __ ] Constitution overturn
that's the Jews I'm running with
[ __ ] so you better check
yourself before you wreck yourself
big Dixon gas is bad for your health
that data is the Lord state
[ __ ] if you ain't doing a
Bonnie shut this off and if you're 18 go
[ __ ] yourself get the [ __ ] off this
periscope you little [ __ ]
go do it jugs jigsaw puzzle or some [ __ ]
go discover black people do something
with your [ __ ] lives yeah cuz they
still home scared of black people get
out there go mingle go buy some crack
and get beat up you don't know what life
is do you fight crack and get beat up by
mistake that's how high and this thing's
been empty for to [ __ ] come over here
practice for an hour thinking of myself
why's nothing coming out is there's
nothing that conductor not smoke crack
anyway you give it back you go down
there for practice just to learn how to
function around [ __ ] black people
another minority I'm saying these
[ __ ] parents today these kids live in
Studio City then they want to send them
away the college name they realized what
happens in the kid fumbles cuz Laurel
Canyon is the biggest Boulevard he's
ever been on yeah teach him how to deal
with black people Mexicans you gotta
take him to the hood and throw him out
of the car this outfit given an hour if
you can survive here for an hour I'll
send you away to college [ __ ]
that's how it's done that's how you
raise a [ __ ] kid
they don't know they listen to their
[ __ ] goofy friends those are little
half of facts I'm gonna lay in college
they fall due within a [ __ ] year
ain't that about a [ __ ] anyway Jeff
Sessions this one's for you that's a
doctor police side foggy follow me
get the book breathing you'll do bong
it's like a savage part of my [ __ ]
seven-day bong workshop next summer
we'll be doctor police's book so you
might as well get it you could be the
valedictorian of the class you know I'm
saying anyway you know I love you
[ __ ] youtube.com slash c / Joey
Diaz is the place to be the 10 greatest
albums of all time guys and I'm not
talking about [ __ ] Fleetwood Mac
rooms that's one of my favorite house
I'm talking about and how I'm that you
listen to that's your favorite ow
because it meant something to you how's
that before you that's a deep [ __ ] up
question right there not what's on the
top 10 UK how are your buddies I love
the red chili pepper yeah you don't know
you don't know nothing you just saying
that so you get invited to the party you
piece of [ __ ] anyway you don't me
bonkers for Jerry's kids if you only go
bananas but Sunday night's the night
they call anybody could party on a
Friday Saturday [ __ ] them they're
sitting there right now resting [ __ ] you
we [ __ ] the rest of all weekend on
Sunday night when that's when the real
predators are going out when do you
think Harvey Weinstein got his dick
sucked on Friday is no Sunday night
after like tonight he gets six [ __ ]
the Golden Globes and be the golden
balls for Harvey Hollywood shave his
nuts and he wouldn't even wear underwear
the event he just had like a little cape
and open up his dick and one of his
young actresses is so gone I mean anyway
don't say this to nobody I'm just
telling you that's the inside info I
heard you follow me
let's do another bonnet I'm gonna get
this podcast started all right so listen
youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz is the place
to [ __ ] be don't forget 10 days
from tonight Austin Texas Thursday
Friday Early's available don't comply to
me Joey you never told me I don't know
don't rate La Hoya taping this [ __ ]
CD Smashing [ __ ] Motley Crue's
gonna be there kiss is gonna be there
the Red Hot Chili Peppers are gonna be
there
croak this is gonna be there so if you
ain't there you [ __ ] up
this is beamed or a CD taping in San
Diego this is from [ __ ] Los Angeles
down if you ain't there you ain't dick
up La Jolla it's an intimate setting you
can smell the [ __ ] when somebody takes a
[ __ ] in the bathroom you can smell in
the room it's an intimate setting but
they were all gonna be done at Nikki
Sixx Chinese people fireworks it's the
year of the [ __ ] dragon [ __ ]
so get your [ __ ] together these events
is starting to come down dog the world's
gonna end soon kim jung woon he's [ __ ]
lighting firecrackers as we speak the
little [ __ ] with a fucked-up
barber was his [ __ ] Baba
don't they have any barbers in [ __ ]
career what [ __ ] Jeff Sessions [ __ ]
young moon and [ __ ] anybody else that
buck - this were America [ __ ] America's
strong you follow me that weed was grown
in America Jeff Sessions what have you
done lately one of you employed somebody
with your pencil neck George Jetson
hairdo
he looks just like George Jesse yeah I'm
saying well anyway I'm not gonna bore
you with this Jan I say Quan I'm just a
little upset right now but do another
bong in and then we'll call nightly how
many stars you I see you thrown them
away shaman eg we got eight three more
we're going for ten tonight with
starting it's a it's gonna rain the
money where you gonna [ __ ] know how
we do it will you kid oh my God look at
this this is how hard we used to
practice I'm not talking about garbage
Ethan I'm not the one of my smells like
a [ __ ] the arms [ __ ] I'm talking
about this is grateful judge Jim look
what's left of this look at this oh just
that timely [ __ ] it let's go home and
watch The Exorcist look at this
another this [ __ ] tent beandoor Izzie
you win littered wall in town for
commies swing you're not coming down
I'll give you $15 [ __ ] I'll give you
20
I'll give you beautiful c.j I'm talking
about you got to spread the love you
gotta eat those muscles Jeff Sessions
meanwhile you're spreading [ __ ]
nothing you're spreading hate jeff
Sessions you no different than those
[ __ ] Nazi haters you follow me in
Georgia in Virginia when they show up
with the [ __ ] with the Izod shirt and
[ __ ] you know different you don't stir
up the pot some people take it away
[ __ ] marijuana you dumb [ __ ]
especially in our Thursday going into
the weekend you announce [ __ ] like that
of a Monday you [ __ ] where's your
diplomacy you [ __ ] then you go to
college anyway youtube.com slash c /
Joey Diaz it's the place to be ten times
of all time nice and quick we'll put on
a few videos we'll get the [ __ ] out of
here right you know I love you
[ __ ] with all my I remember
Monday hey listen whatever happened last
week they can suck it dick tomorrow's
the day you're gonna work with a smile
you take out your nutsack and say
[ __ ] captain yum-yum juice is here
you're [ __ ] with the wrong
[ __ ] you follow me
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz I see
who comes up this and Cinco we know -
remember what I told you didn't get my
might tell our finger but got a drunk
alcoholic
oh yeah you'll say copy time that book I
said it I love you [ __ ]